okay so I mentioned this before the
break let's get now to the full
embarrassment that was Donald Trump's
acting chief of staff Mick Mulvaney on
Fox News Sunday with Chris Wallace
yesterday this will be something
different we're gonna look in detail at
an interview and there is so much to
learn from this interview that Chris
Wallace did with Trump's acting chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney I already played for
you the short clip in another story of
Mick Mulvaney claiming that even though
Donald Trump is the President of the
United States that that's just one of
his gigs effectively that Trump still
considers himself to be in the
hospitality industry so we won't go back
over that that's ridiculous enough what
was actually far more embarrassing was
the way in which Mick Mulvaney came
completely unglued trying to deny
directly to Chris Wallace's face having
said things that are on video which
Chris Wallace was prepared for and threw
right back at mimic Mulvaney's face with
clips and it is glorious now you don't
often see this in media in the United
States in general and when you do it's
not usually on Fox News but I am I
believe that we are in such a desperate
circumstance when it comes to proper
preparation by an interviewer for
interviewing someone that you believe is
likely to be deceptive and to be ready
not only with video clips but with facts
and quotes and the demeanor to actually
question it that this is what we have
and I want to go through it with you
we're gonna look at a bunch of this in
pieces because not only is the subject
matter important but it's good to be
able to parse it it's good to be able to
understand how Chris Wallace structured
it and there's a lot to be learned from
this and the other thing to keep in mind
is this is much more common in British
news media this is much more common in I
watch a lot of Argentinian news this is
much more common in Argentinean media
where in the u.s. very often with people
in positions of power once they give you
the same non answer or lie two or three
times you just move on and it's a
combination of not wanting to push the
interview in a way where you are at risk
of maybe losing access to the person or
an administration combined with the time
constraints of corporate media Chris
Wallace does not let it go and you
actually expose Mick Mulvaney as the
absolutely immoral Trump brown-noser
that he is willing to just tell lie
after lie after lie let's look at the
first clip alright let's have the
conversation yeah why here's my first
question why did you say in that
briefing that President Trump had
ordered a quid pro quo quid pro quo that
investigating the Democrats that the aid
to Ukraine depended on investigating the
Democrats why'd you say that getting
inside what I said that's what people
said that I said here's what I said I'll
say it again and hopefully people will
listen this time there were two reasons
that we held up the aid we've talked
about this at some length the first one
was the the rampant corruption in
Ukraine Ukraine by the way Chris is so
bad in Ukraine that in 2014 Congress
passed a law making it making us
requiring us to make sure that
corruption was moving in the right
direction so corruption is a big deal
everybody knows it the president was
also concerned about whether or not
other nations specifically European
nations were helping with foreign aid to
the Ukrainians well we've talked about
that for quite a while now I did then
mention that in the past the president
had mentioned for me to time to time
about the DNC server he'd mentioned the
DNC server to other people publicly he
even mentioned it to President Solinsky
in the phone call but it wasn't
connected to the aid and that's where I
think people got sidetracked this
weekend at that press conference but two
reasons for holding back the aid of it
let me pursue that that sir because I
believe that anyone listening to what
you said in that briefing could come to
only one conclusion let's play what you
said sir that he also mentioned to me
and past that the the the corruption
related to the DNC server absolutely no
question about that but that's it that's
why we held up the money you just
described is a quid pro quo it is
funding rolled off
unless the investigation into the into
the Democratic server happened as well
we do we do that all the time with
foreign policy he mentioned the
corruption and that's why we held up the
money and we do it all the time
with foreign policy all the time we
withhold aid for things like this is
what Mick Mulvaney is saying so Chris
Wallace comes back after Mulvaney tries
to filibuster for a little while and
says yeah but hold on Mick what about
the video where you said it and mauvais
me immediately starts to come apart you
were asked specifically by jonathan karl
was investigating democrats one of the
conditions for holding up the aid was
that part of the quid pro quo and you
said it happens all the time
go back and watch what I said before
that I don't think eyes can cue it up
and that there was a long answer about
corruption and a long view totally send
out like I told you then and then I said
exactly the same thing I just said now
so he starts to just do double speak and
a minute later after again filibustering
Chris Wallace Wallace goes back at him
with more clips which he has prepared
another moment where Mick Mulvaney said
exactly the thing Chris Wallace is
accusing him of having said despite
Mulvaney attempting to deny it to Chris
Wallace's face and you know I hate to go
through this but but you said what you
said and the fact is after that exchange
with jonathan karl you were asked
another time why the aid was held up
what was the condition for the aid and
you didn't mention two conditions you
mentioned three conditions and i want to
and let's listen to all three of them
cuz you stated it very clearly let's
listen three issues for that the
corruption in the country whether or not
other countries were participating the
support of the ukraine and whether or
not they were cooperating in an ongoing
investigation with our department of
justice that's completely legitimate not
only did you say that investigating the
democrats was one of the three
conditions not to that you had just said
that you had talked about investigating
the democrats was part of the quid pro
quo you
so said if I may it was part of the
Justice Department investigation into
the origins of the Russia probe but so
Wallace keeps going and to his credit
these officials count on that if you
tell the same lie over and over again to
corporate media eventually the
interviewer is going to move on either
because they don't want to get in
trouble with the administration or they
want to save face or they're pressed for
time or whatever the case may be but
Chris Wallace is not moving on each time
Mick Mulvaney looks like more of a liar
which he is look to the facts on the
ground thinks that you can actually sort
of certify and what should put this
issue to bed is that the money flowed
without any connection whatsoever to the
DN sensor you in your first episode
which I gave you said that's why we held
up the money first you just said here
that it was for two reasons now you're
acknowledging it was for three reasons
if you held up the money for three
reasons
that was that's a quid pro quo they've
gotta satisfy on us on those now maybe
the president backed off that but that
was the proposition here I'm not
acknowledging this through resilient
let's go back that's ready to go back to
the I recognize that go back to what
actually happened in the real world I
love that you really have to be careful
with these guys because they have media
training Mick Mulvaney knows at least in
terms of demeanor and verbosity how to
talk to corporate media and to come away
sounding like he makes sense even though
he's saying a and then the opposite of a
Mulvaney says I never said that there
were three reasons and Wallace says well
you did I played it for you and Mulvaney
says I acknowledge that if you're a
casual viewer you're hearing Mick
Mulvaney in a 60-second clip deny that
he said there were three reasons for the
aid being withheld and also say I
acknowledge that is he saying that he
acknowledges having said it but he
misspoke is he saying he acknowledges
that actually there were three reasons
even though he's out of the other side
of his mouth telling you that there were
not actually three reasons what does it
mean it's confusing what it means is
that he's a liar of course
then Mulvaney gets to the disastrous
phone call transcript which of course
was not a transcript it was a few
plucked paragraphs from the transcript
which was released Trump released it
thought it made him look great
it actually was an incriminating
transcript in reality just a truncated
summation of the call excerpts of the
call and now it really starts to go bad
for Mick Mulvaney because Chris Wallace
was prepared for the phone call
discussion in the briefing you flatly
denied any connection between holding up
the aid and investigating Joe Biden and
his son right correct okay in his phone
call with President zolensky however
President Trump specifically meant as
the Biden's do me a favor
front lawyer Rudy Giuliani pushed all
summer for Ukraine to announce it was
investigating Purisima the company that
paid hunter Biden and a former NSC
official testified this week before
Congress john bolton was so disturbed by
the way you were directing people to
work with rudy giuliani he said quote i
am not part of whatever drug deal he was
speaking metaphorically
of whatever drug feels sundaland a US
diplomat and Mulvaney are cooking up no
question you were following the
president's orders but your fingerprints
are all over linking aid to Ukraine with
investigating the Biden's okay no that's
not true let's go I'll take one of those
at a time which is the Bolton thing
because I read that and I was surprised
because John Bolton never complained to
me about it know what at NS C ever
complained to me about anything that was
going on i I didn't see soglin's
testimony this week cuz none of us have
seen sonless testimony which is another
story entirely I did get a chance to
read his opening statement when he said
that Bolton never complained to him
Fiona he'll never got a chance to
complain to him I think you need to put
sort of a wait a minute Fiona Hill is
the one who testified that's the clothes
came from never complained to solid
about what was happening when it was
handled she complained to her boss John
Bolton who did what who said he told her
to go immediately to a lawyer right at
the NSC and to complain about works for
John Bolton yet John Bolton didn't go
say anything to anyone
doesn't that raise a red flag with it
but let's go back to the first when you
talk about which is the president's
phone call because at the end of the day
that's what this is really about right
that's why we are here well this I don't
know about that I don't agree on this
was mixed Comiskey mischaracterized this
is another technique okay
understand that this is a technique that
officials under pressure will often use
it's a sort of Gish Gallup we're instead
of answering the crux of the question
instead of getting to the heart of the
matter
they give four different pseudo
rebuttals two minor points that don't
actually refute the substance of what it
is that's being discussed but it appears
to the untrained by that I mean not in a
pejorative way to just casual news ORS
who have lives and go to work and take
care of their kids it appears as though
Mick Mulvaney has refuted the narrative
that Chris Wallace has presented when in
reality he has the big picture is
Mulvaney as an obvious liar he's trying
to suck up to trump until Trump turns on
him because Mulvaney will be ridiculed
in the same way that Giuliani for a
while was pulled off the air because it
became too embarrassing movi knee now
has been very publicly doing lots of
interviews in the wake of the Ukraine
Fiasco he may end up getting pulled
Chris Wallace was well prepared here
Chris Wallace was prepared with clips
and with knowledge and with quotes and
he does something that I try to do when
I interview public officials when I
interview a scientist I go in with my
questions prepared to learn I want to
learn from the scientist when I
interview an elected official I want to
go in anticipating what their answers
are going to be to my questions and how
they may attempt to either distort or
not answer and that's exactly what Chris
Wallace did here and as prepared as
Chris Wallace is still when someone like
Mulvaney comes in prepared to filibuster
ready to question minor points in a gif
calleb format even an experienced
interviewer like chris wallace can get
thrown off track in the moment and
that's something that unless you're
doing interviews like this can be
difficult to understand how it happens
but overall very solid moe
vanie looking like the dishonest Trump
brown-noser that he is and we'll be
posting clips from this interview on our
Instagram page as well I hope you'll
follow us there at David Pakman on
Instagram while you're in your Instagram
app give me a follow as well at David
Pakman